listen I'm value taming I've interview
billionaires Mark Cuban Magic Johnson
you know worthy Gloria Allred Robert
Shapiro Jordan Bell for all of these
different characters we venturi but I've
never had an interview where so many
value Tanner said we need a part two and
that was when Michael Franzese and I sat
down we did this interview called
highest-paid mafia boss tells the truth
about the life it got millions of views
if you go on YouTube right now you type
in a search word mafia interview and you
saw for most views it's the most viewed
interview ever on the topic of mafia on
YouTube so this time on our part two I
asked him a little bit more specific
questions many of them that you asked me
and the questions were John F Kennedy
who killed John F Kennedy was the Mafia
involved with the mob involved what was
the role they played right we also asked
my Jimmy Hoffa people want to know where
is Jimmy Hoffa buried and another
question that was asked is is politics
dirtier today then it was 4050 years ago
when they were doing what they were
doing you'll be blown away by his
answers this is a Patrick made David
first part 2 when Michael Franzese enjoy
it do you miss the mob lifestyle you
know I'd be lying if I say it didn't at
times but you know people ask me all the
time viciously do you miss the money do
you miss the power yell that you know to
a degree I mean look it's great when you
have anything you can want at your
disposable because you got enough money
to take care of it mind I have my own
jet plane I had a Lear 25 a at a
helicopter I had a couple of big
automobile agencies that I owned so I
drove whatever car I want and you know
basically at homes all over the country
so yeah that's nice but you know what I
really miss I missed the camaraderie
that we had with the guys you know we're
so attractive to me about that life is
hey when you come in it's a brotherhood
don't ever worry about your wife your
daughter your sister we got their backs
wherever you go you know if somebody
hurts you we got somebody to back you up
that's very powerful very very powerful
and I miss that kind of camaraderie that
I had so yeah I also nice you know going
into the back room I want to tell you
this for those of you that saw
Goodfellas Henry Hill he never walked in
through the back kitchen of the Copa
and I can tell you that now but I did
many times first with my dad and then
later on with myself you know it's nice
to go in and get a ringside table and
share eat it that way so to say I didn't
miss it you know I'd be lying
what's the give me one of the you know
craziest experiences you had just
because you had clout being who you were
parties you attended people you were
what was a social life like when you
were at the peak of your game well you
know people who cater to you all the
time you know there's a fascination with
that life Patrick I don't know exactly
what it is maybe the way we carried
ourselves at times I don't know but
people wanted to be around us and they
wanted to treat us right for the most
part especially in social places like
clubs and and restaurants and places
like that crazy experience I had I going
to a place one night and I had
reservations a fairly new place and I
get there and they didn't know exciting
to my name but they hadn't seen me and I
said Michael Franzese I'll be able to
three people and no we want to sit down
on our table and I said Michael Franzese
he's here already
I say he's here already I said well show
me who they are you know I go there my
hand to God was two FBI agents sitting
up they they use my name they didn't
know that I was coming into the place
that they used my name so they see me
and I said I said all right let them
stay there it's okay we'll sit in the
back and they wanted to get up but that
you know I mean stuff like that usually
ah that's interesting do you think
somebody today can take that game to the
highest level like it was before or
would today as many cameras and stuff
that's around that it's not possible to
get it to that level I don't think so
because the other thing is law
enforcement they're too sophisticated
they got too many weapons there's too
many informants on the street you know I
give you an example back before the RICO
Act came out you know we got sentenced
you know 10 years 15 years anybody can
do that you do half time you do a little
bit more than that any guy can on a
streak and do a 10-year hit today okay
they grabbed that same guy like they did
with Sammy the bull and they put him in
a Cell and they say listen get used to
it because his where you're going to
spend the rest of your life if you don't
cooperate do you think that's a good
thing they're doing well listen I want
to make this clear for those that are
listening I I in no way will glorify my
former life it doesn't deserve to be
glorified and the reason is this Patrick
more than anything else I don't know any
family of any member of that life that
hasn't been totally devastated I don't
mean hurt
I mean devastated including my own now
not my wife and kids
you know but my mother my father my
brothers and sisters our life was an
absolute disaster because of my father's
involvement in that life and it's the
same across the board for anybody and
any lifestyle that does that to families
and innocent people
is an evil lifestyle and so I will never
glorify it for that reason now I don't
talk about my fly look I was one of them
I'm just fortunate to be where I am so I
don't badmouth anybody in that regard
but what it's it's a tough life and
it'll never be the same because of that
reason what happened here now is guys on
the street after they got locked up they
become more fearful of what's gonna
happen to them from the government than
they are from their own people and
that's that was the key that's how they
want interesting so the answer would be
today would be very difficult to get it
to the heights that you guys had in yeah
absolutely because of all the different
technology that the government and cops
and all those guys have yes in place
today you know everyone's watched the
movie Jimmy Hoffa whether it's the first
one played back in the day sly played a
movie called fist I don't know if you
remember when he during the movie fish
oh yeah
and then obviously Jack Nicholson did
what he did when he played rate
performance rate performance so what
really happened with Jimmy Hoffa
there's a lot of conspiracy no one what
you know what happened with them I get
asked this question it's a number number
one or two question I get asked all the
time no matter where I am I could be in
the Far East and they're asking me that
question about Hoffa that's how popular
it is but you know look he did get on
the wrong side of people when he came
out of prison he was told to lay low and
just stay back and he refused to do that
didn't want to give up his position
there's no question he was taken out by
my former associates now the question is
always where is he buried that's what
everybody wants to know I can tell you
this he's not in the Meadowlands that's
for sure
New Jersey the stadium he's not there
and they will never find Jimmy's body
never no I had nothing to do with it but
you know you hear things in that life
but I will tell you this if you remember
a couple of maybe a year and a half ago
two years ago
I in prison writes a book and says he
knows for sure where Hoffa is married
and he leads the FBI to the place
allegedly they dig it up now I had
answered this question a thousand times
over the years so all of a sudden I'm
getting tweets and I'm getting emails
and texts Michael maybe you were wrong
you know they're digging it up this guy
says you know he's gonna identify I said
well let's wait and see they never found
his body
the guy was smart though he sold a lot
of books you know you know by saying
that they'll never find you so when you
say they'll never find them what does
that ring because in my mind let me tell
you what my creative mind goes let me
take my creative mind and maybe I'm
right maybe I'm wrong when you tell me
they'll never find them it's either a
body went through a recycling machine
either the body was chopped up I did
something happen with it's
mathematically impossible to find it
burned body something like that where
it's not buried is that the direction
you're going let's put it this way if
you if you wanted to find his body or
try to find his body
you'd have to look in a very wet place
got it and how deep is is what place
pretty deep pretty deep got it okay now
and I gotta teach him I know that for a
fact 100% 100%
do you know location well I I know the
general area I've got it and actually
you know it was really interesting that
a friend that I hadn't seen for a long
time came out of prison maybe two and a
half years ago and he recorded a tape
that I have in my possession and that
tape spells everything out because he
was with the shooter that I happen to
know very well and he laid it all out
and people have been trying to get that
tape from me for a long time Wow now can
anybody can the government come to you
so lucky since you know what happened
that you got to tell us or do this who
how do how is it they know how to
present they can't write because at this
point you don't have to give any of this
information now so you gonna you gonna
be buried whether you gonna go home with
this information no one's gonna get it
addy I believe so
okay because I but you never know no you
know what a right price if we do movie
maybe we'll make a movie
and tell the story did you ever send a
meeting and you saw a guy that went a
little bit overboard we're talking and
next week or the following day the guy
was dead those types of things happen a
lot not a lot fairy you know I want to
clear this up too and I think this is
something I get asked this all the time
you know look it's a violent life at
times you're part of the life you're
part of the violence there's no question
about it but murder in that life was
taken very seriously it was taken very
very seriously you couldn't just go
around rampant killing people I don't
like this guy I want to kill him you
know a made guy had a lot of respect and
if that guy was in trouble first of all
the only one that can order a murder was
the boss
he had a sanction it you couldn't do it
without his okay
not even a made man or a couple it
hasn't all of us has to be the boss and
there was a lot of discussion about it
it wasn't that hey this guy's got to go
okay go get him tomorrow that's the end
of that no it was taken very very
seriously because remember the life is
built on respect when you earn your
stripes and you come into that life
you're respected guy so if something you
did wrong or they're gonna make sure it
was wrong and then if you violate the
oath you know you're gonna pay the
consequences but it was something taken
very seriously you know a lot of people
think that we just went around and
random killing people and the money
though the most maybe like that
yeah I mean I certainly didn't witness
that in my lifestyle you didn't witness
that in your not random stuff Reynaud
ran it was tricky taken very seriously
Bible Michael went window when the piss
don't think happened do you remembered
when it had on after how many people did
that take down how many people did he
take down god I believe over a hundred
it was a big big I mean it was bad how
do you do that for six years undercover
how did he pull that I still don't
understand how that can happen because
even after that case he was doing some
stuff in Milwaukee he did stumps some
stuff in Tampa he was a New York kid
himself so how did people not know who
he was for him to go undercover force it
shows you that the security we had or
certain people had in place at that time
wasn't very good because it should have
never happened
it should have never happened and look I
knew Lefty
you know and I knew that crew not great
but I knew them pretty well they just
slipped up their slips years yeah six
years I mean they did a background check
we know it's part of the problem of that
life
you know you get a guy like lefty you
get some of those guys that are really
not earnest bigger owners and you get
somebody to turn it could put a few
bucks in that pocket they get a little
sloppy they don't look that far back and
I'll tell you I had that experience too
okay I get contacted in a minute was a
huge case they called it shadowboxing I
get contacted by a guy that was with
Muhammad Ali the FBI took him out of
prison and put him in this undercover
operation along with an FBI agent that
went undercover his name was Victor
Clint Ana and he allegedly was a drug
dealer at one point in time they cleaned
up his act but had a ton of money wanted
to get into the fight business so they
come to me can you introduce us to Don
King I'm with these people for eight
months okay all the while they're
recording everything that I do
I had like 83 recordings on me I take
them finally through our sharp dinner
house shopton was it done for hire I
worked with him a lot
alright and I make out sharp then set up
a meeting with Don King to bring these
two guys to meet King so we go there and
first I check out the FBI had set up a
bank account they had 15 million dollars
in a bank in the Midwest the FBI said oh
yeah yes I bring them to King Wynn Kings
office I go in there first I said Don
let me tell you some I know these guys
seven or eight months there are high
rollers that driving a Rolls Royce we
went to Florida together they want to
meet you I said but I don't know him
past that I said so when we talk in here
everything's got to be legit
I'm say anything wrong everything legit
let me keep looking for him and the
meeting went great bottom line is they
were asking for more money to continue
the operation the FBI said no because
after a year they still couldn't do
anything and then the whole thing fell
apart we found out later that it was an
undercover operation Sports Illustrated
Wow huge deal on it but 83 tapes they
were never able to nail me on it they
refused to prosecute because I never
thanks to my dad I never said anything
on the tapes that were could you tell
who was an undercover or no luck was
there a fee could you read them or know
some of these guys were well very well
you know what he was well-trained and
I'll tell you we used to play
racquetball and he used to tell me I got
my back hurts all the time he was
wearing an aggro tape recording at the
time those big things not as
sophisticated as today and I never
patted him down because we were four I
liked them a lot
you know what now we're friends today
yeah he retired from the FBI yeah he's a
great guy we got to like each other so
much you know that interesting
he's great guy great guy like him a lot
he's living out and I think Arizona what
a ranch terrific guy let me ask you when
Joe was doing what he was doing Donnie
Brasco when it was in what he was doing
did you ever meet him did you ever did
or you did I Matt was it an easy just
not a big deal encounter with them yeah
cuz I never did business with those guys
God only he was just a thing we were at
a security session for all of pro sports
and they had a panel I always me Joe
Pistone's some other FBI agent when we
got through the question I said Joe I
should you act more like the mob than I
could be the agent you could be the mom
yeah it yeah he's like he's so in
character till today am i right I stick
to myself here's what I asked Mario
afterwards I said Mario let me ask you
who acts like he's a mob more Michael or
Joe Mario says Joe walks around like
he's part of me he's still in character
character you know I say oh my gosh I
should Joe you ki you can fool me right
yeah when I was sitting with them you
know I interviewed Clint Hill okay I
don't know if you know Clint Hill he was
there yeah a Secret Service agent under
for presidents and he was am a Secret
Service agent for Jackie Kennedy and I
asked him a lot of different questions
and that till today if you go on YouTube
you type in JFK assassination you type
in Clint Hill is the first video that
pops up it's getting a lot of a
commentary right now with Clint Hill I
said listen you know so many people
don't believe this story on what
happened and one people don't believe
this story of the angles well notice
this guy know this is who didn't that
who forget about that part for a second
I'm not trying to ask you you know what
angle was it and what's the real story
here's what I'm trying to ask you when
the Kennedys were coming up his father
was not the most straight you know he
was a blue you know he Joseph Kennedy
who was a big part of the market
manipulation I think when Roosevelt
hired him to bring him in and say listen
what do we need to do here and they they
came out with fingerprinting for
licensing the guy came out with SEC so
it was very much involved in knowing how
to manipulate
the marketplace he was involved with the
mob based on some of the stories you
read about strong personality so that
you read and say well the mob helped
Kennedy get elected I don't know that
I'm asking you so my first question is
is the answer to that yes and to once
Kennedy got elected the follow-up is
it's been said that once he got elected
they try to distance themselves from the
mob to to look like they were good so
nothing would happen the mob got upset
about it and when they got upset about
it because they couldn't fulfill their
commitments they made to the map the mob
said we got to do something about it and
they went about doing what they did to
hire who they hire to shoot him and then
etc when he walked off the mob killed
him now this is some of the stories
obviously a lot of this is conspiracy
but one of the best conspiracies to read
about is Kennedy people are so
fascinated by having said that what do
you know about the JFK situation there
well understand my father is through
that whole era and many of the guys that
I knew her through that whole era so all
I ever heard and that I know to be true
okay and there's no upside in me saying
this I'm not writing a book about it
nothing but there's no question that Joe
Kennedy was involved he was a bootlegger
you're not gonna know cause no question
okay and I know for a fact that somebody
wanted to kill Joe Kennedy during those
times because I heard that he was
robbing money wasn't doing the right
thing and his life was spared
this is 40s this is those in the forties
fifties during that era
he's a bootlegger you're not a
bootlegger unless you're dealing with us
guys that's it okay no question also
okay that threw his father John Kennedy
was we wanted him in the White House and
he was a connection as far as we were
concerned so yes through Chicago through
Louisiana he was they did help him get
elected they did help absolutely union
votes and you wanna know about this I
know this for a fact okay guy and now
the government's never gonna want
anybody know this they're gonna call me
a liar and all that kind of stuff but
that's the truth Patrick and as far as
the assassination I mean come on
did Jack Ruby come out of nowhere I mean
he had all of a sudden these mob ties
mean anything if you had mob ties with
me they would want to say it all over
the world oh yeah you connected with the
mob all of a sudden ruby who was
connected with the mob not as saying he
wasn't you know they never want it to be
known that the mob had a hand in that
assassination because it makes him look
horrible
government doesn't want anybody know
that but I mean I've heard that
consistently throughout my my whole
tenure in that life all the time you
know Giancana and Chicago and and so
when he got killed you're saying the
assassination is linked back to the mob
yes now again it's been said it's not
true he's a liar I have no upside in
saying this other than this is what I
know to be true throughout my whole time
in that life I heard her from My Father
I heard it from everybody that I know
that was in that era I was there I was
younger obviously I mean I wasn't coming
up at that time but but it was shortly
after I mean I'd begun I got recruited
in the 70s it was a couple of years
after he was killed so that story was
fresh no doubt so let me ask you as
dirty as politics was back then how
dirty is it today
more or less Patrick I have never and
now understand something yeah did I see
them when we were on the street we
understood the government a lot of times
cross the lines with us we got it but
you know what we were criminals so in a
way can you justify it I don't think so
I don't think the government is ever
supposed to act illegally okay they're
supposed to abide by the law we were
criminals we broke the law but they're
supposed to use the laws effectively and
properly to get anybody that's my
feeling well you know what all right we
were criminals and they cross the line
every once in a while okay I have never
in my lifetime seen the level of
corruption that is going on today in the
political come on Michael I'm Patrick I
kid you no more today than before hunter
absolutely and at a level that I can't
believe I mean look I've experienced
this is my life experience you
understand I've been indicted five times
I've had two federal racketeering cases
I've had two state racketeering cases I
I've been in front of the Supreme Court
on constitutional issues in my dad's
case I've been in front of the appellate
court so many times I've been more grand
juries than you can imagine this has
been my life I understand that
I know the law and I am Telling You I've
never seen the law violated by people in
power like I'm seeing now it's to a
point where I can't even watch it
anymore it's it's terrible because it's
bad for all of America look we cannot
let our political authorities cross the
lines of what's legally correct we can't
let them do that because it's a threat
to everyone at that point in time and
I'm not being biased I have many friends
in law enforcement many friends and they
were honest cotton they'll tell you
straight out we don't approve of what's
going on it retired FBI agents that I
know now it's sickened to what they'd
seen it Wow
I mean come on this is I mean look I
mean even call me what's going on in his
book tour I mean the things that he's
saying that it coming out of his mouth
it's an embarrassment to the FBI in my
opinion because there's a lot of
hard-working you know honest legitimate
agents that do that job and a guy like
this in my opinion is tainting
everything else I mean it's terrible
terrible I've never seen this level of
corruption and I'm being honest what can
we do about it what can be done about it
you know I don't it seems to be so out
of control because people are not aware
they don't understand this you know when
you allow the government to cross the
line it doesn't only affect the people
that crossing in line it affects
everybody yeah they do what one person
they can do it with another no doubt
about it Michael what age did your dad
become a mobster about what what age did
he become a made man or get into that
life the oldest living man in America my
dad he's been a made man for over 68
years he was in his yeah he was in his
30s 33 when he became so 32 33 when I
became a made man correct I mean he was
an involved in mob life prior to that
because you don't just become a made man
your first year was he part of it for
about 10 years or so my grandfather was
not a made guy but he was very respected
by a lot of made guy got it he just
didn't want to be that got it my father
was one of had three brothers they were
all kind of street guys but my dad was
the only one that aspired to be part of
that life my dad was an amateur boxer he
was a tough guy street guy and he was
recruited by the mob and he wanted to be
a part of it and so he went through the
thing and he took the oath like me
Michael I think what would be very
interesting is for us to do something
with you and sunny you and your dad if
we sat down and we did an interview
there that would be a whole different
story cuz he's still you based on what
you're telling me he's helped he can
still talk he still his brain works the
same as before and he can still process
issues that be a very interesting person
to be talking to he goes back to the
days of Luciano and Costello God he'll
even tell you about Capone because he
was younger than but he knew Capone came
out of New York so he's right on it
stuff with capsule well he knew him I'm
not saying I don't know what he exactly
did but he knew him I asked my dad I
tell you this my dad was he got so much
publicity in his sixties now he wasn't
the main guy around okay there was a lot
of guys doing Columbo everybody was
around but for some reason they targeted
my dad and I got to tell you this story
so I went to one time I said dad why you
why he's a lot of guys around why did
they pick you he said my mom has passed
away five years ago and he said I never
wanted to tell you this I don't want to
disrespect your mom but now that your
mom has passed away I'm gonna tell you I
said what he said I was dating Marilyn
Monroe Kennedy fell in love with a Bobby
Kennedy he was the Attorney General at
the time she made him understand that
she was in love with my father
from that point on Robert Kennedy
targeted my dad because of the Marilyn
Monroe went after him like crazy now
sometimes my dad oh you know I'm
wondering okay dad you turning me but it
made sense I said dad you tell him he
says I'd swear dad was with Marilyn
Monroe yeah and he got a little bit more
graphic when he told me this is I'm not
gonna repeat it here but but yeah and
then you know I'm starting at there and
I said where did you meet her now I
start questioning a me he says I I met
her at the Stork Club
that was the hot place back yeah right
Costello had a piece of it and I said
okay tell me how it happened he tell me
the whole setup and everything else and
you know because Hoover wasn't targeting
mob guys back then he was a friend
because you had information on him on
that information yeah he was bisexual
you know he got caught and blah blah so
he never went after guys because they
held it over his chest that there is no
mob is what he said there is no yeah all
right but Kennedy was a different story
and he targeted my dad for that reason
you know what so
times I think my dad but I believe this
one I absolutely believe it because I
put a two together I did my little
research it was true so so you can brag
I mean you know it's pretty impressive
to be able to brag that your dad hooked
up with Marilyn well let me tell you
that is impressive
I got to know next time I got to get
your dad the first issue of Playboy
magazine and send it to him and say look
you know here's a reminisce about who
you used to be back in the basil what a
story bother well let me tell you I love
for him to tell that story my my dad's a
great storyteller and I light a dish he
has never done an interview in his life
he's never done anything so we did it it
would be an absolute first 100 101 year
old mobster the oldest living guy legend
in his own right
has never said it never did in it never
said more than five words to the press
that was it and rumor has it your dad
went through a lot of me he really he
was a brutal guy when it came down to it
he didn't hesitate for a second no my
dad was he should die he's the right
number last a number is pretty up there
he's not a he doesn't have a small
number he was the last of a dying breed
but I'll tell you one day I respect my
dad they can put in front of a firing
squad
he's dying with his boots on they'll
never get him he'll never say a word
he'll never give up that life he took
that oath seriously would you live the
life all over again wow that is a tough
one the answer would be now because I'm
a I'm a I'm a guy of faith now and I've
turned my life around I can never go
back to that because I know that I did a
lot of things that I regret during that
time but take that away what I want to
go back and at least have that
experience again I'm being honest and I
might get ridicule for this but I think
I might you to have the experience
because look you know I learned things
in that life that were invaluable to me
throughout my life and if you takeaways
the bad stuff and just put me back in
that environment around my guys and some
of the I think I might
and again I'm hope I'm explaining this
right because you're gonna have a you
gonna have a 50,000 young kids right now
go become mobsters no no no gotta say
the right now I don't know I don't want
you know about you tamen produce twenty
two thousand two mobsters and no no no
no no let me make that clear let's give
the disclaimer as well I mean let me
make that clear I said it's an evil life
I said you're selfish if you put your
family through that
you're gonna end up in prison or dead
one of the two governments got at all
and it's morally wrong I mean there's no
question about it but look there was
some perks in that life you know that I
I've enjoyed I got to be honest with you
now the price you pay as a result of a
short time that you're gonna have those
perks is terrible because you're
devastated for the rest of your life so
it doesn't make sense I speak to a lot
of young kids I speak to gangbangers I
go into detention halls I have an
influence over them obviously and I tell
them straight out you're gonna be being
prison for the rest of your life
or you're gonna die it's one of the two
things and they'll say to me but but
Michael you know I saw you in Goodfellas
and they had the money that had the
power to had the girls I said yeah but
did you watch the whole movie or did you
just stop in the middle
I said who got killed who went to jail
who became an informer whose wife left
them whose kids suffered why don't you
see that part and you know what they
don't they only focus on that they don't
realize it's very short-lived and at in
the end you're going down and so please
anybody listening parent don't get upset
with me I I speak to these kids and I
tell them the truth
it's a bad life don't ever pursue it
don't ever make the mistakes that I did
Michael what would have happened if you
became an entrepreneur what happen if
you went into the business right and you
applied the same skills that you've you
picked up well I like to think I would
have been successful look I had a lot of
legitimate businesses also you actually
had a lot going on with you had stuff
going on with dealerships you own all
these different things with culture guy
I bought a Mazda agency when you
couldn't give a monster I remembered I
remember reading cuz the Wankel engines
were exploding you couldn't give one
away and I built that into the biggest
agency on Long Island as far as Mazda
was concerned and it was a lot of work
and I had to do things differently what
I was able to build I think I had a head
for business I had a knack for it now
you know don't get me wrong
I'm not the smartest business guy around
because there's a lot of things in
business I don't enjoy doing but there
was certain talents that I had that
worked well for me
and I always tell people this when
you're in business I don't think it's a
good thing to micromanage because nobody
can do everything good but here's the
deal do what you do best and delegate
the rest and then be a good you know
watcher of these people make sure you
get the most out of them that's how you
do it you know I've got comments from a
lot of people saying Pat I love the
interview I mean I learned so much but
some also asked me said Pat why are we
interviewing mobsters on value Thema
well the reality part of it is if you go
on Patrick Brady be calm I list the top
100 movies every entrepreneur must watch
you know it's number one on my list
Godfather you know why because it's all
power plays if you are not a little too
paranoid in a world of business
someone's gonna take you out so again
whether you like it or you didn't
comment Blanc you know what your
thoughts were about what he said with
Jimmy Hoffa John F Kennedy and if you
haven't watched the interview go watch
the actual interview part one it's
fascinating we'll put the link below as
well and for some of you I like content
like this I did a video titled 25
lessons you can learn from mobsters if
you haven't watched it you may want to
go check that video out take everybody